22 c'est le nombre d'oeuvres peintes par
l'artiste c215 pour son exposition
épopée montceau nien louis xiv louise
lan ou encore voltaire ils représentent
des personnalités liées à l'histoire de
maisons laffitte
il ya des maréchaux d'empiré il ya des
acteurs des sportifs et des romanciers
et un philosophe
voilà donc c'est aussi des portraits qui
remontent pour les plus anciens jusqu'au
xviie siècle avec la fondation du
château avec anne d'autriche et louis
xiii et qui font remonter jusqu'à le
plus récent c'est grégory baugé qui est
un donc un cycliste qui est champion
olympique
les supports utilisés sont divers livres
chaise ou encore murs de la ville les
portraits ont été réalisés au pochoir
technique de prédilection de l'artiste
ma spécialité c'est de peindre des
pochoirs dans la rue ou sur des objets
c'est aussi la dimension insolite de
l'expo il ya beaucoup d'interactions
avec les objets c'est toujours des
oeuvres contextuel qui tendent à se
fondre un peu dans l'environnement mais
qui se détache dès qu'on les remarque en
fait donc ce n'est pas spécialement des
oeuvres qui s'impose à la vue aussi bien
dans château cos dehors mais qui
lorsqu'on les remarques ensuite sort
resteront en fait une partie des
portraits est présente dans les
différentes pièces du château l'autre
dans la ville à travers un parcours
urbain l'art dans la ville c'est la vie
même dans la ville est donc une ville
vit avec des associations etc mais doit
vivre également avec des oeuvres
artistiques et ce soir c'est 215 a mis
quelques pochoir dans la ville avec des
gens célèbres qui ont fait notre ville
nous sommes les héritiers d'une longue
lignée d'ailleurs le dirait brel au les
portraits exposés à l'intérieur du
château sont à découvrir jusqu'au 30
novembre